foreign
[Music]
I'm hearing here that the team is
looking into those upper level wins
before we proceed with the situational
briefing we should have an update here
in just a few minutes
thank you
[Music]
and also don't count down that is the LD
we're holding a clock at T-minus 20
minutes 2-2 upper wind violations stand
by for a new t0 time
and as you just heard from clay the team
is going to hold at T minus 20 minutes
we're going to continue evaluating those
upper level winds and get a new t0
foreign
[Music]
thank you
those white clouds that you see coming
out of the rocket are due to venting of
the chilled gas from the rocket into the
humid Florida air out here that's why
the gas condenses into vapor and looks
like clouds when it's coming out
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]
thank you
foreign
for those just joining us we are at T
minus 20 right now and we're actually
holding the clock due to upper level
winds the team is currently evaluating
this and we'll provide an update as soon
as they have it however the vehicle is
healthy and the range is currently green
so as soon as those upper little ones
slow down a little bit we'll be able to
provide another update
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
I see you
[Music]
laughs
thank you
[Music]
foreign
for those just tuning in we did hold the
clock at T minus 20 minutes today but
we're expecting a briefing in the next
five to ten minutes on what's happening
with the upper level winds that were the
reason for us holding the clock we'll
continue listening in and hopefully
everything sounds good
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
for those just tuning in we once again
held the clock at T minus 20 minutes due
to weather issues unfortunately upper
level will winds are currently marginal
so the team is evaluating live data to
determine if we can go ahead and keep
rolling the clock or if we need to pause
for a little bit longer
and as we wait on that additional data
on the upper level winds and as we get
an update from the team let's go ahead
and take a moment to get an idea about
all the work that the integrated
performance team does for relativity
space
hi I'm Ryan Kraft I'm Katie Wallace my
name is David Brown I'm the director of
Integrative performance at relativity I
made a vehicle simulation
and I'm a Staff vehicle simulation here
one of the key things that we focus on
in the department is connecting all the
different teams making sure the
structures work with the engines the
engines work with the software and the
software works with the electronics
Hardware I was lucky enough to work in a
few different Hardware startups this is
actually number five for me worked on
electric vehicles race cars rockets and
manned spacecraft I
stay in the Life immediate relativity
and Vary a lot in general it'll involve
[Music]
D Mission planning tasks and also
building up new simulation capability I
spent my entire career working on
simulation controls I started off
working in the automotive industry on
hybrid vehicles and later moved on to
Motorsports and general Consulting for
other Industries when I saw what was
going on in relativity here about three
and a half years ago I realized this is
the coolest place to be on earth and I
wanted to join the team some of the
things that we get to learn every day I
don't think you can learn anywhere else
and the team that I get to do it with
just makes it even sweeter specifically
some of the big challenges are around
figuring out what parts of accepted
practice in the rocket industry still
make sense for us and where we should
change things or when we should just
throw it out and start over with a
completely new approach I think one of
the most exciting challenges is getting
to work on taranar especially because
our team gets to be really involved with
the early design running different
trades and analyzes and trajectories and
it's challenging because it's never been
done before but it's really exciting to
really get to help shape this new
vehicle my role is usually involved
taking small components systems and
integrating them into complex system
models which then have like great
predictive capabilities
what I find most exciting about this is
then taking these models and using that
capability to help guide design work
there's a lot of places where an
engineer can come in today and still
Define how relativity will do rocket
engineering for the next five to ten
years when we look for candidates in the
integrated performance team the main
thing that we're looking for is hunger
to face really hard problems and
excitement to learn as you go we're just
looking for people with different views
different experiences and different
ideas to find the right way to do a
reusable rocket next time around I think
someone who would be a great candidate
for relativity would be someone who
enjoys working on complex problems and
solving difficult challenges having any
background with simulation or launch
vehicle modeling is always helpful as
well as orbital mechanics or General
Physics backgrounds one thing I would
suggest for candidates can be from more
traditional physics backgrounds is to
basically demonstrate that you have the
experience of taking the analysis that
you've performed on a computer and
turning that into actionable Insight
that you can share with the team and use
to help guide design decisions right now
the team's about 40. we're looking to
double that in the next year or so we've
been growing a lot in the last year but
definitely a lot more to come as we get
ready for taranar and all the fun
physical challenges there one of the
very unique opportunities here
relativity is being part of a lot of
technical firsts we printed our first
rocket we're testing it right now we're
about to go through our first launch
then our first customer and eventually
our first re-entry Landing of a booster
and reuse of it one thing that people
might not know about working in an
integrated performance team in a rocket
company is that a lot of us didn't have
a rocket background when we came in
people come from Cars software
development engineering analysis planes
missiles I feel like the opportunity for
a really fast-paced learning across a
very broad range of technical topics so
you can't really find that anywhere else
I think what draws people to relativity
it's a unique type of physics
it looks like we are coordinating a new
t0 right now that is going to be at 14
35 Eastern we're awaiting confirmation
from Mission Control at the moment so
we're going to continue listening into
them for any further updates
foreign
[Music]
and now the t-clock is rolling again we
are now 38 minutes away from our new
scheduled launch time of 14 35 Eastern
again that's 14 35 Eastern less than 40
minutes away
oh
[Music]
foreign
okay
[Music]
thank you
we're now at T minus 31 minutes and you
might be wondering where we built the
launch vehicle that you're seeing on the
pad we currently have two manufacturing
facilities in Long Beach California and
today's rocket was printed at our second
Factory called the portal while our new
headquarters named The Wormhole is home
to our fourth generation Stargate
printers this is the million square foot
facility we are currently expanding into
that will serve as the epicenter for a
teranar development and production
speaking of terenar turn one is truly a
Pathfinder to that vehicle the real
opportunity in the market as proven by
our customer contracts we are actually
already ramping up production for this
medium to heavy lift reusable vehicle we
have designed it to be capable of 20 000
kilograms to low earth orbit or Leo and
we plan to still benefit from the
large-scale metal additive Manufacturing
one key learning from turn one is with
the engines let's take a look at this
clip of the Aeon R thrust chamber
assembly test
so what you just saw there was a full
power test of the aonr thrush chamber
assembly I want to give a special shout
out to Jake Sherman senior manager of
combustion devices the propulsion test
team and the stennis test teams for
accomplishing that critical Milestone so
full power means 258
000 pounds of thrust at sea level that
is what we are designing a on our engine
to and that is 10 times the capability
of the aeon1 engine that we have on turn
one today
we are already well underway testing
components such as a full-scale gas
generator test igniter testing and as
you just saw that full scale thrust
chamber assembly
we are currently building our integrated
engines and on our Twitter feed you can
actually see an image of our first
integrated engine next to a human for
perspective on size we are also
completing building of our turbo pump
assembly and we're planning to go into
full engine tests in throughout 2023 and
we're going to test those engines over
at the NASA stennis Space Center in
Mississippi where most of our testing is
done in 2018 we secured the first
commercial space launch act or csla
agreement with NASA stennis and we now
occupy several operational facilities
there including four exclusive use test
stands for Terran one stage and aeon
engine testing two stands used for a on1
engine tests and a onr component tests
and one cell for an R engine tests on
top of that we're building out an
additional 150 acres for the taranar
program and we've already started
construction on the new engine test
stands other structures there will
include a full-scale second engine stand
Office Buildings and of course an
integration hanger all the structures
we're completing out there are built
from the ground up on previously unused
land
after testing we ship the components to
the launch site we of course have our
operational site here at the cape but
we've also acquired a site in Vandenberg
California as an additional option for
future launches in 2019 we secured a
direct agreement from the U.S space
force for launch complex 16. and
relativity joins just a few others here
as only the fourth company with a
currently operational orbital launch
site at Cape Canaveral both tan 1 and
Taran R will launch from launch complex
16.
with that we are now approximately 27
minutes away from launch this is so
exciting I hope we continue to move
forward but just as a reminder we do not
have a customer payload on board but we
do have a Memento in the nose cone we
have included our first ever 3D printed
piece from our Stargate printer of
course it was a failed print since no
one had done it before let's go ahead
and take a look at this memento
so that piece that you see there is six
and a half inches in diameter and weighs
about three pounds it is our first
completed circular test article for
which we used our first generation
aluminum alloy since then we've added a
machined centerpiece with a glhf for
good luck have fun and our mitosis logo
to commemorate this Maiden launch and
from our very first failed print seven
years ago it's taken a Relentless focus
on Innovation and almost countless
iterations to get to where we are today
the world's first 3D printed rocket on
the launch pad here at Cape Canaveral
like the first print Taran one is the
first step of many towards making
Humanity a multi-planetary species
as a reminder our primary objective for
today is to gather as much data as
possible to help develop our future
Vehicles including terenar our larger
medium to heavy lift reusable launch
vehicle
now we're currently at T minus 25
minutes we're going to continue standing
by for further updates from Mission
Control
thank you
foreign
t
y situational briefing for
Rigo no go
all parties be aware the go no go poll
will be performed at approximately
10 minutes
primary test objective is a transition
into countdown through terminal startup
and release into flight
fecal status propellant is loaded we are
tracking no additional items for
constraints
and while we are still waiting on one
final balloon we are still a go unless
that balloon comes back as negative
all assets are standing by for launch
and we will do polls in approximately
six minutes stand by all parties
and you just heard that situational
briefing from Clay Walker the vehicle is
very healthy right now and the only
issue that we're tracking is
unfortunately the weather but we are
awaiting data the latest data from our
weather balloon to determine if we can
continue and go ahead with our scheduled
launch time of 14 35 Eastern
as we continue to wait maybe let's do a
recap on the turn one architecture and
go ahead and look at this graphic of our
turn one architecture
as a reminder turn one is 110 feet tall
and seven and a half feet in diameter we
have two stages that are expendable on
the bottom we have nine a-on-one engines
each has a Thrust capability of about 23
000 pounds at sea level giving us a Max
total liftoff of more than two hundred
thousand pounds the aeon1 engine is
designed with a gas generator cycle and
as you previously heard we have thrust
vector control actuators or tvcas on the
engines that allow us to gimbal during
flight
we have completed more than 2 000 engine
hot fires as we prepared going into
launch today
on one engines are attached to the
vehicle through a Thrust structure and
above the thrust structure we have Wham
printed tanks are what previously shared
that this is the wire Arc additive
manufacturing in-house process that we
use and these tanks hold liquid oxygen
on top and liquid natural gas on the
bottom
during flight we pressurize our tanks
using an autogenous pressurization
system this means that we tap some
propellant from the engines and this is
run through heat exchangers mounted on
those engines and converts the liquid
propellant into a gaseous State and we
pipe it back to the top to maintain the
required tank pressure or oledge
pressure
above the stage one tanks we have a way
on printed interstage which holds our
stage separation mechanisms this is what
we use to separate stage two from stage
one during flight
the stage separation system uses
pneumatic pushers
and above the interstage is stage two
which has a single aeon vacuum engine
this engine has a Thrust capability of
more than 25
000 pounds in vacuum and has the
capability of multiple restarts stage
two is also when printed just like stage
one
and above stage 2 is our Wham printed
nose cone which we just shared about the
Memento inside of that nose cone for
future missions we will replace this
nose cone with the Fairing and also
include a varying separation system
turn one was designed with the payload
capacity of
1250 kilograms to Leo or 900 kilograms
to Sun synchronous orbit or SSO
all the data from today's launch in turn
one development will be fed into terenar
but note that
NRC RCS checkouts complete
we're gonna go ahead and pause and
listen in on mission control for any
more updates thank you
as of now it seems like everything is on
track and we're going to perform the go
at no-go polls in just a few minutes
here so we're going to stand by to
listen into Mission Control
foreign
[Music]
thank you
all parties are all Nets this is the go
no go for launch
please provide your currents to proceed
into launch with launch count don't go
no go
BC BC go BC go DC One GC go she's ccko
gc2 gc2go gc2go ground ground go ground
go avi avi go Avi go FTS FTS go FPS go
RF RF go all right let's go GNC GMC go
GMC go flight software apply software go
flights offers go prop one prop one go
prop one to go prop two prop two go drop
two go clue it's one lose one go so it's
once go who it's two
those two go loads loads go let this go
rock ranges go right just go osm osm
let's go osm let's go RC RC go RC go
vehicle vehicle let's go Eagles go ce's
go C's go LC LCS go LC just go all
parties ever party go for launch
countdown
wants to clap against the roll anyone
can call for a hold at any time if a
hole is called prior to T minus 70
seconds the t-clock will continue to
roll until T minus 70 seconds at which
point of hold will be automatically
initiated the hold is not possible after
T minus 70 seconds any holds call after
that time will result in a terminal
count aboard
should hold our manual abort be
necessary the person call for a hole or
board should stay clearly on comms hold
hold
or abort abort abort in the event that
osm requires a hold of osm will initiate
the hold command on the osm GUI and
notify the LD and the RC on the primary
net
and you just heard our launch director
complete the go no go polling with our
mission control team as you heard all
systems are currently healthy so as of
now we're able to proceed with our
scheduled launch time in just about 13
minutes
throughout today's live stream you've
been hearing call outs from Mission
Control now let's take a moment to
introduce you to our mission control
team
as you just heard Clay Walker launch
director John wiswell launch conductor
James Harris chief engineer Elijah
Escobedo and Zoe dickert on vehicle
controls Brian batters Ground Control
Bill stack ground Joy mazdell range
control
we also have a few notable members of
leadership supporting today's launch and
they are also here at launch control
with us this includes our co-founder and
CEO Tim Ellis our chief operating
officer who leads product execution Zach
Dunn vice president of test and launch
Don catterbeck and director of Cape
operations Pat zvatek these are among
many many others who are making today's
launch happen
let's go ahead and take a moment to wait
as we get more updates for Mission
Control
for those curious you'll be able to see
small white pieces falling off the
rocket not to worry that is just ice
falling off from the frost on the
vehicle due to the chilled propellant
inside
on the other view you might have also
seen a small flame to the far left of
the view and that is just the flare
stack that's used to burn off any
flammable gases from propellant loading
and venting operations
once again those white clouds you see
coming out of the rocket are due to the
venting of the chilled gas from the
vehicle into the humid Florida air out
here that's why the gas condenses into
vapor and looks like clouds
thank you
in just about 46 seconds here we will
begin our countdown sequence
thank you
[Music]
if you might have 10 minutes countdown
sequence has started
and we're currently at T minus 9 minutes
and 45 seconds in the upcoming minutes
you're going to hear several call outs
from mission control as we go through
the final pre-launch procedural steps
including the priming of the igniters
final engine checkout transporter
erector retraction and getting that
final go for launch again we're now
pressing the tanks to flight pressures
as you just heard and we're currently
proceeding with our scheduled launch
time
in just about 30 seconds we'll be
transitioning stage one to helium
and I'm receiving an update here we just
got the data from our latest weather
balloon and we are a go with upper level
winds the weather isn't stopping us
today
Angela pneumatics have transitioned to
helium
and that means we're pressurizing the
propellant tanks to flight pressures
with helium as a reminder
we'll pressurize the tanks with
autogenous pressurization
that last call out was that we're
pressurizing the tanks for engine chill
we're now getting into the business end
of today's countdown let's take a moment
to walk through the launch timeline
at T minus three minutes the transporter
erector or that black trust structure
will retract just a few degrees to give
the proper angle for umbilical
separation at this point the vehicle
will be on internal power then at T
minus 70 seconds the vehicle will go
into terminal count this is again when
the vehicle's internal flight computer
takes control of the countdown and we
then go into a final flight termination
checks and flight targets and get FTS go
from the launch conductor in
coordination with the mission flight
control officer and Operation Safety
manager at T minus six seconds we'll
have ignition of those nine beautiful 3D
printed aeon one engines so you'll see
the Flames beneath the rocket at that
point and at t0 we will have liftoff
shortly after that at two plus two
seconds the strong back will throw back
to assist in removing the umbilicals and
clear the path for the vehicle to fly at
two plus twelve seconds it will begin
our pitch over program and at t plus 80
seconds is that important Milestone of
Max Q or the point of Maximum Dynamic
pressure this is again where the
structural loads on the vehicle are the
highest making it one of the more
challenging phases of flight
at approximately t plus 160 seconds we
will get to Main engine cutoff or Mikko
this is when the stage one engines will
shut off this will be followed shortly
by stage separation and ignition of the
Aeon vacuum engine
second stage will burn for a little
under five minutes and then at
approximately t plus 463 seconds we'll
have second engine cut off or Seco as a
reminder we do not have a fairing or any
payload deployments for today's first
launch
we'll go ahead and continue listening in
on Mission Control
we're currently priming the igniters
with gaseous oxygen and gaseous hydrogen
our ignition system uses these
propellants flowing across the glow plug
the stage one igniter is priming in
Michigan
as a reminder glhf is our Maiden launch
so while a nominal flight would have
turn one reach orbit today our primary
goal is to learn as much as we can and
demonstrate the product concept the
major Milestone would be to have Taran
one make it through a Max Q the point of
Maximum Dynamic pressure
stage two is on internal power
and you'll now see those cradle arms are
slowly starting to release stage two at
the top there so that the strong back
can retract
each one PVC checkups
over the next minute and a half we'll be
performing the final thrust vector
control Health tracks on both stages
before liftoff you'll be able to see the
engines gimbaling or tilting if we're in
that engine view there we go
stage one is on internal power
strong back retracting
and now that black truss structure
behind the vehicle will retract just a
few degrees to prepare for umbilical
separation
foreign
[Music]
as we approach T minus two minutes what
you're looking at on your screen is a
vehicle that is 85 3D printed and it is
about to fly
next up our range coordinator will ask
the range for their final grain status
[Music]
range
you heard that call out someone is
calling a hold due to the range we're
gonna stand by for updates
there appears that there may be a vessel
within our clear radius we're gonna
stand by to hear confirmation from the
range
thank you
foreign
and I just got confirmation there is a
boat in the range we're gonna stand by
to see if they can clear the boat from
our radius
once again just to clarify our vehicle
is healthy and all systems appear to be
performing nominal we just gotta go for
the weather for upper level winds but
unfortunately there is currently a boat
in the range so we're just still waiting
confirmation to see if they can clear
that boat in time and get it out of our
radius
and also don't count on that as the LD
we got a hold called prior to terminal
count
hold getting items have been cleared we
are adjusting for a new t0 time it will
hold the clock for terminal count until
we pick up the count
all right now we are just confirming a
new launch time all items that were
blocking us and giving us a red range
have now been cleared out so we're going
to await that updated launch time and
then update the t-clock above as
necessary
shh
all right and the clock is about to
resume just shortly here they are
coordinating that new t0 we're very
excited to get this thing going down
there two clocks should pick up in 60
Seconds
60 Seconds
we have confirmed our new t0 is going to
be 14 42 Eastern once again that's 14
42. we'll see the t-clock rolling in
just a moment here
peacocks rolling terminal count
Hello darling what's up
like computer and countdown came out of
60 GC with the count
LD or you go for launch
buildings go for launch
and we just got that final go for launch
from our launch director
range is green we're now about 30
seconds away from the moment that we've
all worked so hard for our first launch
we've had a lot of fun with you turn one
good luck and here we go
as you can see we had ignition of our
engines but the t-clock did hold at t0
we're going to stand by for updates
foreign
all right I'm hearing from Mission
Control that we're currently assessing
Vehicle Health to confirm if we can do a
recycle today and try this thing one
more time
thank you
[Music]
announcement I'll count on that this is
the LD
terminal count on a large commit
criteria violation the T minus 0.5
seconds prior to liftoff
or shaking the vehicle and assessing
recycle opportunities
as you heard once again we had a
violation with our launch commit
criteria which is why we had an abort
shortly before liftoff the team is
continuing to assess vehicle Health to
confirm if we can have a recycle today
as a reminder we're currently at 14 50
eastern time and our launch window is
open until 1600 Eastern so our teams are
currently assessing any recycle
opportunities that we have during this
time
thank you
you'll see an occasional Cloud coming
out of the transporter erector or the
black truss structure there that is just
because we're creeping our propellant
topped in case we can re-attempt a
launch before the end of the window
today at 4 pm Eastern
foreign
as you can see the t-clock rolled back
we are still working on a recycle so
we'll keep you updated as soon as we
have confirmation
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
clock is rolling again everyone we just
have an updated launch time of 15 55
Eastern once again 15 55 Eastern in just
under 44 minutes we're gonna keep going
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I just got an update from our engineers
and Mission Control we are updating the
t0 time to
1600 Eastern once again that is 1600
Eastern T clock is rolling
[Music]
oh
my God
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
for those of you that are tuning in
today we're going to take a moment again
to introduce ourselves my name is
Rachelle anacedo I am the chief of staff
for the vehicle architecture and
Technology team
and I'm arwa tazani Kelly technical
program manager for test and launch here
at relativity space
now ahead of turn one's liftoff we
invited some of the most influential
voices in the space industry to curate
some questions from you all on Twitter
about our journey to launch we
appreciate the time that Michael sheets
space reporter at CNBC Eric Berger
senior space editor at ARS Technica and
Tim Dodd the everyday astronaut took to
answer your questions let's take a look
uh this one this question comes off of
Twitter from Danny Stover many launch
companies fail their first attempt well
Taran one reached the same fate what
makes relativities approach different
um I want to hear Michael what do you
have for that one foreign
first launch attempt is I think a great
example of the high risk aspect of the
development process and I think that's
one thing a lot of people need to keep
in mind is there's along the way to
development even before launch there's
all these Milestones that you're trying
to get through including you know as
we've seen recently static fire so you
pass those Milestones you get more data
As you move closer and closer the end
goal is can we not just get into space
not just get into orbit but deliver into
the targeted orbit get to the place we
want to actually be and I think a nice
analogy of it is like ordering an Uber
you want an Uber that's going to get you
the closest to your destination
ideally your front door but if your Uber
is dropping you off you know a couple
miles away you're probably not going to
continue you know using the app anymore
because you're going to try to go to the
competitor who's actually getting into
that ideal order it so will it make its
first attempt is that open question and
I think I really want to stress the
development side of where the company is
because people see failure at kind of
any state and they go oh this is a wash
um but it's really important to
understand that ultimate goal of an
intentional specific orbit
I'll answer the question a little bit
more bluntly I do I do think relativity
probably will fail on their first launch
attempt if you look back at no new space
company has ever restored it on their
first flight attempt you know you had
rocket lab fail SpaceX failed on their
first attempt
um uh virgin orbit failed Firefly failed
APL failed
um and so you know it's the odds are
against them and more credit to them if
they succeed and I also think that the
3D printed nature of this structure is a
big a big test are you going to be able
to see that get through Max q and then
there's some more complex elements on
the tear in one rocket that you might
see in a more traditionally developed
launch vehicle and I think you know I
think seeing a nominal first stage
performance would be a pretty big win
for relativity and I'd love to see him
get to orbit on their first time out I
just think historically the odds are the
odds are pretty long against it
yeah I'm definitely with Eric there uh
you know I realized just recently that
you know the Pegasus when it first
launched was one of the only Rockets to
successfully make it to orbiton's First
launch so uh and you know that was
definitely not by any means considered
new space by today's standards
um but realistically you know yeah like
Eric said the odds of being completely
successful on the first round is
statistically about zero so I'm just
excited to see if they can get through
the first big milestone if you know if
they can yeah make it through Max Q if
they can see stage separation you know
each staging event is definitely one of
those big unknowns until you do it for
the first time you know can you light
your upper stage engine can you you know
deploy your fairing can you eventually
you know if you get to deploying a
spacecraft from uh you know on orbit
that's just that's the ultimate
Milestone of course but yeah those those
are there's a lot of things uh between
there and leaving the ground so yeah
time will tell I mean I think only of
the companies we've talked about outside
of Pegasus and and that was orbital
sciences and of course that a solid
fueled rocket and most of which was not
developed in-house like the commercial
space companies today
but you know of the companies we talked
about only rocket lab got to like a
second stage engine ignition in Flight
right on their first their first mission
yeah
yeah 21st century wise that's definitely
true and I think another way to tackle
this question is defining failure
because you know when you talk about
many companies fail their first attempts
you need to understand the you know the
multi-step process of a rocket launch
and I think that's an another important
aspect where depending on how far they
get towards their ultimate goal you know
it will categorize whether this is a
learning experience from a failure
standpoint or this has a lot more to
build upon in in every step that they
complete during the launch is another
check mark towards success
yeah absolutely
this next question comes from Han
Tronics with the capability of 3D rocket
printing will we see a day when rocket
engines are a part of the ship structure
such that their major components won't
need to be removed inspected or replaced
after every launch I don't remove my
engine in the car every thousand miles
I think there's always going to need to
be some kind of repairability and and
separateness of the components of the
structure of the vehicle and the engines
I mean there's just an inherent you know
physical moving Parts you have bearings
you have valves you have components that
uh that just would need to be expected
on on any vehic inspected on any vehicle
and uh you know if you completely
integrate that into the structure to the
point of not being able to uh remove and
service it you just really you know you
really limit yourself now if you're
talking about an Expendable launch
vehicle uh there is the potential that
integrating it could actually add
potentially some reliability uh or
Simplicity or mass savings so
um it depends on your overall goal if
you're talking about a reusable vehicle
they're flying over and over and over
completely integrating it to the point
of not being able to even remove and
service it is probably not the best idea
in my opinion
I would just say that you know this is
an impossible question to answer now
because we have to see a 3D printed
Rockets are capable of flying
um you know then that's the great thing
what I love about the launch industry
today is you've got all these companies
trying different things right you've got
abl out there trying to basically build
a miniature Falcon 9 as simple as
possible a modular approach you know
ship it and shoot it from a launch pad
um you have you know virgin orbit trying
air launch you know you had Astra trying
to build the cheapest perhaps less
reliable rocket
um and and you got relativity doing
additive manufacturing and so it's it's
great to see all of these different
approaches
um because you know we're going to try
them all out and and it takes a real
world test I think to get the right
answer ultimately
um I'll do this one this is this one
comes from Kyle a Mame asking what other
markets in the space sector or Beyond do
you see Stargate technology being
applied in I kind of mentioned it
earlier I would love to see uh you know
large-scale additive manufacturing be
used for you know automobile prototyping
uh race car prototyping especially oh my
God like the Formula One World where
every year the cars have new
restrictions and new rules and a new uh
you know set of rules to have to
engineer by being able to scale develop
stuff with a 3D printer makes all the
sense in the world so I think that's a
pretty no-brainer would be the
automotive industry
I think there certainly are potential
other Market use cases but additive
manufacturing you know obviously
predated relativity and they're trying
to apply it in this really significant
way with such enormous structures and I
think that's the fascinating aspect is
you try out the technology behind the
rocket in such a extreme reuse case
where then other sectors can look where
can we apply this where can we iterate
Faster by implementing printing these as
a solid entire structures as opposed to
you know different pieces that you put
into whether it's for shipping or other
large industrial components you can see
the kind of Downstream effects of a
basically a demonstration of hey we can
build a rocket with this type of
Technology what else can't we build
I think Michael's exactly right you know
there's been talk about relativity since
it was you know almost since it was
founded is this a launch company or is
this a 3D printing company I think you
know that that once they sort of get
their hands wrap their hands around
space flight they're going to be taking
this technology into other areas and and
we don't really know what those are it'd
be interesting to find out you know just
for me personally one of the big issues
that we've seen in this country and
around the world has been housing issues
and so I don't know if if 3D printing
these large structures could be applied
to housing units or things like that but
it's going to be fun to find out where
this technology goes
that was a great video answering some of
your questions on Twitter now we are at
T minus less than 30 minutes from our
launch with our updated launch t0 time
of four o'clock P.M Eastern so that is
1600 Eastern we're currently going to
stand by from an update from Mission
Control in the next few minutes
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
no-go polling from Mission Control is
coming up here in just a couple of
minutes around T minus 16 minutes we're
going to stand by and continue listening
in awaiting that pull
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
please provide concurrence proceeding to
launch operations with go no go
GC go
as you can see
my software
probably
who's one
who's two
loads
Rock
s go
osm
RC RC go vehicle
CE
LC LC go
all parties report go for launch
countdown
all right our team is being relentless
here we are not giving up and we're
gonna give this one more shot with an
instantaneous window at 1400 Eastern as
you heard all parties have reported they
are go for launch
and just a reminder 1600 for that launch
and as we continue to wait let's remind
you what we have inside of our nose cone
so we don't have a customer payload on
board but we do have our special Memento
which is our first ever 3D printed piece
from our Stargate printer as we
mentioned before it was a failed print
but this is just special for us as we
get to this moment
as a reminder that peace is about six
and a half inches in diameter and weighs
about three pounds and it is our first
completed circular test article for
which we used our first generation
aluminum alloy since then we added a
machined centerpiece with glhf and our
mitosis logo to commemorate this Maiden
launch
we'll go ahead and tune back into
mission control and wait as we get
closer and closer to Launch
T minus 10 minutes countdown sequence
has started
and you heard that call out we're
currently at under T minus 10 minutes
and in the upcoming minutes once again
you're going to hear several call outs
from mission control as we go through
the final pre-launch procedural steps
including priming of the igniters final
engine checkouts transporter erection
retraction and getting that final go for
launch for this attempt again we're now
pressing the tanks by Target to flight
pressures as you just heard and we're
currently proceeding with our time of
1600 Eastern this will be our last
attempt for today and it is an
instantaneous launch window
stage one we'll be transitioning to
helium shortly
stage one pneumatics and transition to
helium
once again that means we're pressurizing
the propellant tanks to flight pressures
with helium and as a reminder during
flight we'll be pressurizing using
autogenous pressurization
tanks are pressing for engine chill
since we're getting into the business
end let's remind you about our launch
timeline or what take it away
so again at T minus three minutes the
transporter erector or the black truss
structure behind the vehicle is going to
retract just a few degrees to give the
proper angle for umbilical separation at
this point the vehicle will of course be
on internal power at T minus 70 seconds
the vehicle will go into terminal count
and this is again when the vehicle's
internal flight computer takes control
of the countdown we'll then go into
flight termination checks and get FTS go
from the launch conductor in
coordination with the mission flight
control officer and Operation Safety
manager at T minus six we're going to
see that ignition one more time of those
nine aeon1 engines so you'll see the
Flames the blue fire I should say
beneath the Rocket Station igniter is
running in and at 2-0 we'll have liftoff
at two plus two seconds the strong back
is going to throw back to remove the
umbilicals and clear the path for the
vehicle to fly at 2 plus 12 seconds
we'll begin our pitch over program and
then at t plus 80 Seconds we're going to
reach Max Q or the point of Maximum
Dynamic pressure this is again where the
structural loads on the vehicle are the
highest making it one of the more
challenging phases of flight
at approximately t plus 160 seconds we
will get to Main engine cutoff that is
where the stage one engines will shut
off and it will be followed shortly by
stage separation and aeon vacuum engine
ignition our second stage will burn for
a little under five minutes
then at approximately t plus
463 seconds we'll get to second engine
cutoff when that aeon vacuum engine will
shut off and as a reminder we do not
have a fairing or any payload
deployments for today's first launch
with that we'll go ahead and sit back
and listen back to Mission Control
we're currently priming the igniters
with gaseous oxygen and gaseous hydrogen
again our ignition system uses these
propellants flowing across a glow plug
less than five minutes away
stage one ignite is priming in
glhf again is our Maiden launch so a
nominal flight would have turn one reach
orbit today but our main goal is to
learn as much as we can about this
vehicle and demonstrate the product
concept A major Milestone would be for
us to reach Max Q today the point of
Maximum Dynamic pressure
stage two is on internal power
te cradle there we go disengaged you'll
see that cradle arm slowly start
releasing stage two so that the starring
back can't retract
and you can see the engine's gimbaling
there we're performing the final thrust
vector control health checks on both
stages right before liftoff
engines there
front bike retracting
and now that black trust structure will
retract just a few degrees to prepare
for umbilical separation
there it goes
that's H2 TVC checkout
as we approach T minus two minutes just
a reminder the vehicle you're looking at
is 85
3D printed
those white clouds you see coming out of
the rocket are due to the venting of the
chilled gas from the vehicle into the
humid air that we have here in Florida
that's why it condenses into vapor and
it looks like clouds that are floating
out
you'll also see the flare stack on the
bottom right there that is just used to
vent out flammable gases
next up our range coordinator will ask
the range for their final status
Rock report range status
we got confirmation range is grain for
launch
up
it's like computer and countdown
foreign
launch window
we are going to be scrubbed for the day
taking up the vehicle
thanks for playing
our teams obviously gave it an amazing
shot today and we had high hopes for
sending our Terran one off but we're
going to continue to take a measured
approach so we can ultimately see this
rocket off to Max q and Beyond
once we have an update on the timing of
our next launch attempt we will share
that via Twitter at relativity space we
hope you will join us again soon to see
the world's first 3D printed rocket fly
I am Rochelle anaceto and I'm arwa
tazani Kelly thank you see you next time